bonjour lille sans carbonade c'est
toulouse sans son cassoulet c'est ce
qu'a écrit un journaliste gastronomique
c'est peut-être un petit peu exagéré
mais c'est vrai que la carbonade un
pierrot c'est vraiment un des plats les
plus traditionnels du nord des flandres
et je suppose que votre mère en faisait
bien sûr tous les gamins on a mangé sa
et défend on pouvait le faire
c'est un peu le boeuf carottes aussi si
vous voulez rajouter les carottes mais
enfin principe nous la carbonade c'était
à la bière et la cassonade comment on va
faire aujourd'hui bon alors la carbonade
c'est pas une grillade comme son nom
pourrait le laisser croire en fait c'est
un plat mijoté qui est à base de boeuf
un de boeuf ou de vache d'ailleurs parce
que quand on demande un morceau de bois
façon boucher on sait jamais il ya une
chance sur deux pour que ce soit de la
vache
bon vous qu'est ce que vous savez
préparer comme qualité donc des morts ce
soit n'a pas pris les morceaux nobles
appris les voir sous deuxième catégorie
ça disons à breisach ont après morceau à
braiser on appris du jarret et du
et du pal rond donc ces deux morceaux
pour briser des morceaux qui vont
mijoter pendant 2h30 3h
c'est ce qu'on a trouvé bon alors avant
de passer à la recette pierrot quand
même je voudrais rendre un petit hommage
à deux races de vaches de notre région
qui font partie du patrimoine de notre
région nord pas de calais et qui ont
donné au combien de carbonade au combien
de steak frites c'est d'une part la pie
rouge des flandres et d'autre part la
bleue du nord alors la bleue du nord
c'est une race rocky est pas très
important je crois qu'il ya cinq ou six
mille têtes dans cette région nord pas
de calais mais en foyer des éleveurs qui
défendent un 7/7 bleus qui est appelé
ainsi bien vous l'avez vu un et vous
devinez à cause de sa robe qui a des
reflets bleus en tout cas la plupart
d'entre elles pas celle-là thienpont mai
la race bleue est d'origine belge
elle a de grandes qualités elle est à la
fois les tiers et en même temps elle
donne de pas mal de viande également et
il ya un label d'ailleurs il ya la belle
bleue du nord qu'on peut trouver chez
les chez les bouchers qui diffuse cette
viande typiquement régional
[Musique]
regardez-moi ça si elle a une belle tête
bleue du nord le jeu
bon revenons à notre à notre carbonade
de mon cher pierrot alors donc on a vu
les morceaux de viande que vous aviez
prévu tout tombe bien il y en a là aussi
personne j'ai vu douze morceaux de 120 à
150 g
un kilo et demi a dit à peu près de
viande bon alors à part ça qu'est-ce qui
nous vont alors on va faire revenir le
morceau dans le pré sans grades de salou
que j'ai mis à fond pour gagner un petit
peu de temps comme d'habitude oui ça
nous qui est de la graisse de porc halal
est donc donc si vous voulez on a mis à
peu près 100 g donc de saindoux ensuite
nous allons le faire revenir évidemment
pour le colorer nous allons mettre 3
cuir de faerie donc ça fait à peu près à
l'est entre 80 et 90 g de farine
nous allons dégâts c'est qu'un petit peu
de vinaigre parce qu'après vous verrez
qu'on va vous comment va mettre du sucre
et on va mettre de l équivalent de notre
cuir devinette pour dégraisser
nous allons ajouter un litre de bière on
appris de bière de garde du nord a
évidemment puisqu'on est dans notre
région d'après les deux bières ensuite
nous allons rajouter pendant que sa
grille de métro 2 2 à 3 cuillères de
cassonade part avec deux cuillères de
nationale 3 4 tranches de pain d épice
qui va nous rappeler à peu rappelez vous
un petit peu le coq à la bière et le
mélange sucré-salé quand même bien dans
le maroc après nous allons faire si on
voit pour mouiller à hauteur ciment
commettra un petit peu d'eau du laurier
les clous de girofle du sel et en métaux
à bouillir la marmite pendant de 2h30 à
3h à voir celle en affaires bon ben
voilà on va commencer à tendre à
commencer donc je mets un loyer et j'ai
bien sa double sajoo gémissant g de sade
ou à fond et je vais donc mes morceaux
de viande à colorer on utilise souvent
le 112 dans le rabat oui si on joue le
jeu du saindoux dans la rue la grèce
doir et lorient c'est le [ __ ] ça donne
un petit goût particulier ouais bah
c'est quand même disons plus comment je
vais dire ça ça lol plus de goût c'est
un peu comme le cassoulet c'est quand
même meilleur que le beurre dans pour
les viandes pour tous les cuissons les
viandes
alors on laisse que le riz de chaque
côté à peu près 3 4 minutes
jean retour de mes morceaux
tranquillement or l'appareil pièce il me
faut leur avantage du des carbonates
c'est qu'après quand ses cuivres on peut
le laisser sur le côté mijotés et on peu
le réchauffé un peu comme les rats bout
qu'on fait évidemment les ragoût de
mouton
quand vous faites ça le matin
tranquillement ou la veille pour le
lendemain
ainsi les blocs qui se réchauffe très
très bien alors toujours sales et après
qu'on a bien tourné la viande et piquez
la viande à pour pas salé avant si on
file toujours pareil tout le jus de
viande va partir tout de suite
donc faut bien sûr salle et après quand
on a bien tripoter la viande après on
sale va bien on est bien coloré je vais
donc salée
et je vais rajouter les deux trophées
alors on va mettre 3 cuillères de farine
donc à peu près 70 g de farine
je vais mettre mes oignons ya convié
donnions la 300 grammes d'oignon à peu
près sûr que ça bien le goût d'oignons
parce qu'ils ont dû enlever avons bien
crâne et je mets tout ça aussi a
tranquillement et que la farine en même
temps comme étant les stars alors on va
laisser cuire bon pour puis la farine 3
4 minutes et donc je 3 4 minutes et là
vous voyez ça a commencé à colorer et
apprendre des glaces robinet alors le
vynex justement progrès un petit peu
d'acidité parce qu'évidemment comment va
ramener un peu de cassonade et le palais
piste le vinaigre c'est un petit
contraste donc une fois que ça commence
a aussi un petit comme encore laissé de
3 minutes et ensuite on pourra des
glaces et qui appelle des glaces est
alors des glaces et c'est toujours le
ramener à liquide froid sur la vie chaud
et très faible qui comptera c'est ça va
bricoler les particules up qui accroche
dans la casserole c'est comme un petit
onglet échalotes condé glace dans quel
contraste et d'échalotes se décolle
remonte voilà c'est ça le problème de
l'aigle assez d'accord voilà je vais
donc déglacer au vinaigre à peu près de
toi cuillère voyez peu près way au foot
on peut y aller parce que comment va
ramener de la cassolette ces bourses
bon litre de bière à la bière dinars
alors pas de réclamer un petite bière du
ch'ti quand même on déchire bien sûr
c'est une bière brune c'est bien de
gabal légèrement vrai mais on peut
mettre on peut mettre de la bière de
ménage aussi comme il en faut ça suffit
alors on va météorite de bure allait
devenir ces femmes année on va compléter
par de l'eau d'ailleurs on toujours
pareil niveau hauteur de regarder en
complète par de l'eau payé pour juste
les 2 3 cm quand je dis au coeur
toujours deux ou trois centimètres au
dessus
ouais voilà on va ajouter notre petit
rire de cassonade
c'est de la vergeoise en fait un verre
jouer à age mass brune vient jouer ce
brûle et mais trois quatre tranches de
pain d'épicés bien été même vous n'avez
pas fait rebondir parce que ça va
tellement cuir alors c'est la cuire
pendant 2h30 à 3h pierre ouais je vous
cache pas des fois on doit le creux
quand ça va cuire ça qu'il est fort 2h15
de nomades des fois quand j'ai comme
tout à l'heure on l'a dit une belle
vache à lait fois trois heures et demie
ça dépend j'ai comme une belle-mère des
fois c'est un peu plus lent à cuire sa
défense il faut combien l'a34 alors
qu'en mairie vous allez on va rajouter
le teint notre nom notre lauriers mais
j'ai vu dire c'est tout on mettait pas
de pain d'épicés mettez du pain de
campagne un pain de mettre du pain de
campagne allaient connaître des
spéculoos écrasé seysses et il ya
beaucoup de possibilités
voilà
et on va laisser mijoter tout ce petit
ensemble pendant 2h30 à 3h donc en
principe la moyenne la moyenne qu'il
faut surmonter au moins deux heures et
compass qui vante la viande se détache
alors il faut faire bien son fils à la
fourchette et qu'elle ce qu'on sait pour
sacrer chauffer c'est toujours prêts bon
et ben ça bout donc maintenant nous
allons le mettre en veilleuse
ça commence à bouger très fort voilà
pierre on va le mettre donc en veilleuse
et on va le cuire pendant deux 2 à 2h30
à 3h donc vos vérifiera tout à l'heure
pierre il ya deux heures et 15 2 heures
vad que ça cuit et alors eh ben j'ai
assez cuit c'est très bon ouais ça sent
bon ça n'a pas accroché
donc s'il faut quand même payer j'ai
tout y est un petit peu entre deux tout
y est légèrement et on va s'occuper des
vols d'air algérie à cuire et patata
l'eau pour changer et ben oui alors à
courre vos culs de pierre lagourgue
aller avait tourné alors si on la lèvre
garde et qu elles ne s'accrochent pas
c'est qu'elle est cuite celle là il
manque un peu de cuisson on va s'occuper
des cuites voilà donc à peu de choses
près reste plus qu'une ou deux minutes
ouais et les pommes de terre sont cuites
voilée mais se démêlent pas après alors
on va donner un tout petit truc que nous
les cuisines ont un pierre parce que les
ménagères souvent quand vous faites des
pommes de terre à l'eau voulait cuisez
puis après vous laisser dans l'eau
chaude et après le seul mails nous les
cuisiniers on va montrer c'est tout tout
mais quand c'est cuit quand c'est cuit
comme là on va vider à cheer de l'eau et
on va mettre de l'eau froide pour
arrêter la cuisson et pendant une
demi-heure aux pommes de terre ne vont
pas bouger c'est pour ça qu'elle se
démêlent potes dans les restaurants
elles vont rester le dire à personne
voilà donc je les remplacer par de l'eau
froide et maintenant vous pouvez le
laisser sous au ralenti ville avant sur
le côté et donc voilà et votre en
principe votre pomme de terre ne va pas
ce dvd bon et bien on va servir le pôle
carbonate carbonade comédie des pavés du
nord
ouais
voilà allez ça a toujours pareil pierre
jambes est un morceau au oui un morceau
savard et la sauce on va toujours dire
tu es à des petites pommes de terre on
peut mettre un peu de persil on peut
mettre un petit peu de trot sont au tour
je prends un petit morceau pour moi
quand même bichonner aulas comme ça se
voit ça se boit de la bière
vraiment je veux dire avec des amis hier
bien sûr qu'on apprend de delavier ouais
y'a des pierres je vais on va rendre
hommage quand même une confrérie que
j'aime beaucoup
ah oui parce que je sais que vous aimez
beaucoup la bière à la fière fière et
vous avez été intronisé dans la
confrérie du houblon de rares où va le
rendre hommage voilà alors la confrérie
du houblon d'or c'est le confrérie qui
rend hommage à la bière et vous gérez
vous jurer fidélité à la vieille bière
et ben alors soyons en rondelles de
bière et serment à la vôtre
[Musique]